mà chúng ta nếu tốt và thần thần thần, nó bị vấn đề tình dục.
Hì chúng ta sẽ dễ dàng hương rất nhiều.
Chứ còn chúng ta càng nát bao nhiêu, thì chúng ta càng khó khăn với nhiều.
Bởi vì tôi còn mấy mắn tôi còn có vợ tôi nữa.
Bởi vì tôi thì có thể dàng lời, dài quên được những cái vấn đề về.
Đánh giúp những cái vộ phần kiến, rồi là những cái gọi làm về sáng, những cái gọi là những cái bệnh,
bây bệnh, nhưng ý của bù hụng nữa, còn tôi về cả, còn có trái thì có thể dàng hả.
Thần thần nó sẽ vấn đề tình dấu, chúng ta như những người đàn ông nữa sẽ vấn đề tình dấu.
Tôi nghĩ rằng cái cách để chúng ta dài quên và bý qua những cái gọi là những cái hò nổi.
Bằng cái là chúng ta thải nổi.
Chỉ có khi mà chúng ta nổi.
Chúng ta lúc đầu chúng ta có thể hơi nổi nổi nổi nổi nổi nổi nổi,
nhưng mà sau đó thì mọi thứ nó sẽ dễ dàng hơn rất nhiều.